The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today is the
fourth and last lecture
on the sort of
microfounded macro models.
And then next
class, we will turn
to a section on measurement,
which is like a halfway point,
or not really, in terms of
total number of lectures.
But we'll get into them--
to the micro evidence.
I must say, this is sometime--
I said this last time-- in
reverse of what I sometimes do.
I often start with the
micro stuff and build it up.
But this isn't a bad
idea, because you'll
get to see this way how
different assumptions matter
within each of these
models as you compare
the predicted solutions.
So it hopefully heightens your
sensitivity to assumptions.
And then we'll get
into the microdata
and really scrutinize
what we see there.
This paper, in particular,
is part of that conversation.
The way it's organized
in terms of the lectures
is this paper features
mostly something
other than limited commitment.
Almost every single model has
had sort of very limited credit
or financing constraints,
collateral constraints,
basically putting a damper
on sudden transitions
and generating growth paths.
And here, we're going to
be looking at transition
somewhat-- also, steady states.
The main thing is
we're going to be
featuring on other alternative
underpinnings of the models--
costly state verification,
adverse selection,
moral hazard.
Again, the irony, for
those of you coming down
from the advanced
macro class, is
that Alp was featuring costly
state verification up there
early in a lecture.
And these things
are somehow related,
in the sense that the dynamics
that are created with the debt
contracts and so on have
to do with what you assume
about the information structure,
as well as adverse selection
and so on.
So you'll be perhaps
a little relieved
to know there isn't
as much material
on the front end of this
lecture as there was last time.
That's kind of a sad
comment on the literature.
Almost everybody assumes
limited commitment,
so there really wasn't
much to choose from.
We sort of scoured the earth
to find some relevant papers
in this genre.
So there's three,
and the third one
is what I'm going to focus
my attention on, the tree, so
to speak, of the lecture.
And now we'll look
at several trees.
The first two are
a bit different.
This one is Greenwood,
Sanchez, and Wang--
Jeremy Greenwood, as of
Greenwood and Jovanavic,
which was a key feature of
one of the first two models
we talked about in lecture 2.
And he's going to focus
on Levine's comment.
It's kind of cool the way
these things come together.
Levine worried that the
finance causes growth.
Empirical literature
doesn't have
a microfounded view of what
really impedes intermediation.
So that's what this
paper is about.
And it's going to be sort of
a costly state verification
point of view with diminishing
returns and exogenous,
technological progress.
There's a telling sentence.
In the paper, Uganda
could more than
double its output if
it would adopt best
practice in the financial
sector, which is something
like the US or Luxembourg.
Although, there are other
things in the model,
so that that's not
enough to get it up to,
quote unquote, "its
total potential output."
Again, you see this
language of gaps
here that we focused
on earlier in one
of those financial
possibilities frontier.
So this is very
much trying to get
at gaps in terms of
the underlying model.
AUDIENCE: What are
these other factors?
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: What are
these other factors?
PROFESSOR: There's going to
be some technological progress
that varies across countries,
which is pretty standard stuff.
And then this is
kind of layered in,
or it's actually more of
the heart of the model,
given that other.
Well, we've seen that was done
in the China paper as well.
So another interesting
thing, 29% of US growth
is due to improvements in
financial intermediation.
So this paper both has
transition paths in it,
as well as steady states.
This is a comment
about steady state.
There's exogenous technological
progress going on,
not at the level of
the sort of TFP shocks
that are in front of
the production function,
but in terms of the
monitoring technologies which
intermediaries can use to
verify some private information.
And that's where the
technological progress
is that's driving, say, steady
state US growth rate according
to their calibrated
version of the model.
Now, there are two key variables
here that they focus a lot
on-- the interest rate spread
and the capital output ratio.
So let's look at them.
These slides are
interest rate spreads.
This is the US.
That's Taiwan.
This is the spread
in the US, maybe 3%,
maybe declining,
but not so clear--
modestly so.
And this is sort of the
capital to GDP ratio.
And it's paired to Taiwan,
where it's a bit more--
at first at least--
easier to interpret.
This spread is
high and declining.
So this is the transition part.
This is Taiwan experiencing
technological progress that's
lowering, or even I guess
it was in the steady state,
at different levels of
technological progress
in monitoring output.
And as that happens, as the
intermediation system becomes
more efficient,
capital is increasing.
You can make better
use of capital
because banks have
better information,
and they can lend
more appropriately
and adjust for risk
more appropriately.
Now, even then, this
diagram is kind of striking.
Because you can see that this
is steadily rising as the spread
is coming down.
But relative to US, the capital
to GDP ratio is quite high.
So you know, just be mindful.
There's two variables here,
and one of them is GDP.
So low levels of GDP kind
of make that ratio high,
and that's going on and
also moving these variables
as you compare over
time and over countries.
So the idea is that
firms, banks, really
monitor cash flows.
The efficiency depends on
the amount of resources
you devote to monitoring
and to the productivity
of that monitoring technology.
And as well, firms have
differences ex ante
in the structure of
returns that they face.
So they get the
usual sort of why
money doesn't flow from
low productive firms
to high productive firms.
And the answer is
this monitoring.
At any moment in
time, there are firms
with high expected returns.
They tend to be underfunded.
But it's underfunded
relative to this world
with complete information.
Whereas, we're in the
constrained second best world.
Others have low returns
and they're overfunded.
So these are the sort of not
so talented wealthier firms.
That theme keeps coming
up in all the lectures.
In China, it was the
state-owned sector.
And last time it was
firms drawing talent,
and some people having
low talent which
is persisting and so on, which
is sort of what's true here.
And of course, as
efficiency increases,
funds are reallocated
from less productive
to more productive firms,
and the interest rate spread
goes down.
There's going to be perfect
competition in the banking
sector.
So the cost of
borrowing is going
to fall because these firms
are going to be kind of less
able to walk away with the
money in terms of the monitoring
technology.
So here is a picture of
the interest rate spread.
And it kind of goes the
way you would think.
The low interest
rate spread countries
are these highly
industrialized countries,
and they tend to have low
capital to GDP ratios,
in part, because
they have high GDP.
And here's a
cross-section of countries
that vary with respect to the
level of income and the capital
output ratio.
And this is, again,
very similar,
except this is TFP over here.
So you can see that interest
rate spread is a bad thing,
and the higher the spread,
the worse the system.
So as the interest rate spread
goes down, TFP is going up.
So TFP is a function of this
sort of financial efficiency.
Yeah, Matt.
AUDIENCE: What data do they use
for the interest rate spreads?
PROFESSOR: Oh--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
interest rate [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: I don't know if they
grabbed some IMF statistics.
I think IMF financial statistics
[INAUDIBLE] have that.
I'm not sure if
that's what they used.
But basically, yeah,
it's some measure
of the difference between the
lending rate and the borrowing
rate.
And then that sounds
good at first,
until you start thinking about
all the many ways you could
get at the borrowing rate.
Often, these things ignore
the informal sector entirely,
for example.
This is-- which this paper is
doing as well in the theory.
And this is the usual
growth accounting stuff.
OK?
I don't know that we should have
had this on the earlier slide.
You want to predict a
country's per capita income.
It's efficient countries
with higher TFP.
So this is sort of behind
the Lucas thing, which
is why isn't money
flowing very quickly
from low-income countries
to high-income countries,
since high TFP tends to
mean high marginal product
of capital and so on.
But it's amazing.
They almost all lie on the line.
AUDIENCE: Is there
a TFP solo residual?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's just a solo residual.
And that's a good comment,
because this paper
is about the different ways
to decompose at the firm level
the sort of coefficient
that's hanging
outside the front of
the production function.
And then add it up the way
[INAUDIBLE] were doing.
So they also do this sort of
Rajan/Zingales thing, which
is to try to calibrate
against the US economy,
they look at the firm
size distributions
and the interest rate
spreads in the US
to get some of their
parameters, and then take it
to these cross-country data.
AUDIENCE: Sir.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Actually,
are [INAUDIBLE]
distributions similar?
Or is it developed
[INAUDIBLE] country?
PROFESSOR: No.
So what they're saying is the
US would be a more or less
efficient financial system.
So you could sort of
think about grabbing
the relative technology
parameters from that,
and then take those
sort of what are
counterfactual--
those parameters are
put in the context of
a developed country
with lots of other restrictions.
So the idea is to get
the technology right,
and then somehow figure out what
difference the financial system
makes.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What are
the main assumptions
you have to make
in your own model
to get that [INAUDIBLE]
distribution [INAUDIBLE]..
Because I mean,
[INAUDIBLE] then it
seems to be about the
distribution of talent
or distribution of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Each one of these models tries
to be really careful about how
to map the data into the
notation and assumptions
they're making.
And that's-- here, I can
give you a hint of that,
although I can't get to it in
as much detail as I would like.
So here's this
production function.
There is some aggregate shock
that hits all the firms.
There is some theta, which
is an idiosyncratic-specific
firm-level shock.
And then we have the usual--
Cobb-Douglas actually just
noting constant returns
to scale.
Different papers differ on that.
And where do these
idiosyncratic shocks come from?
They're drawn at random from--
in this case, some simple
two-point distribution.
It could be high or low.
But here is over and
above that, another source
of the heterogeneity
that different firms
have different sets of thetas.
So the whole sort
of range domain
can be different, depending
on, quote, "the tau type"
that these firms are.
Intermediaries are competitive.
So they're going to sort of not
get any surplus out of this.
They raise funds from consumers
and lend them to firms.
That's typical
intermediation structure.
And the intermediary
knows the firm's type tau.
However, it doesn't know output.
It doesn't know the
idiosyncratic shock theta.
And it doesn't know
the labor supply.
So all he's doing here
is being careful to throw
in enough sources of unknown
that you can't basically
back out from the output
the unknown things
on the right-hand side.
And he probably could have gone
with different assumptions,
but that's certainly
the spirit of it.
Or at least, doesn't observe
these things costlessly.
But there is this
monitoring technology.
The firms experience their true
productivity, say, high or low,
call it for the theta
i for a given firm.
And suppose the firm lies
about it and says theta j.
Theta's not observed
nor inferred
from any of the other
ex ante or ex post.
Then the intermediary devotes
labor to monitoring the claim.
So this technology
of verification
is actually resource using.
It's another
production function.
And then the size of
the loan is determined.
That's the capitalization
of the firm.
They don't have any
wealth on their own.
That's kind of the
scale of the project.
The level of productivity
and monitoring is z.
So that's kind of like whether
it's a completely noisy signal,
or an extremely accurate signal
of the actual true state theta
i.
So this object, Pij is--
that's the probability
that if the firm
made a counterfactual
report of theta j
and really were a theta i,
with this amount of labor
devoted to monitoring,
given this loan size,
and given this index of the
productivity of the technology,
this is the probability
of finding out
what the truth of it really is.
And so-- and then
this mapping here
is to provide
between productivity
and financial sector z,
which, say, we don't see.
And the things that
we do see, at least
we, as econometricians, see
output and interest rate
spreads.
Now, let me pause for a
second because you might well
think of the obvious
thing is, wait a minute.
Didn't you just say
output was unobserved?
Well, this model and
others make a distinction
between the exposed
data that we have
as analysts about
firm output, as
opposed to what the intermediary
is seeing along the way.
So we're imagining
we do see output
and these interest rate spreads.
Those were the slides
I just showed you.
And then this is
where I'm going to--
Matt-- going to be a bit vague.
If you looked at the
equations in the notation,
they can basically invert
those equations to get x and z.
And you can do it at a point
in time for a given country,
or you can do it at two
different points in time.
If you're getting
z, you're getting
a measure of this productivity
of the monitoring technology.
And that's why,
for example, they
are able to make statements
about Taiwan's productivity
increased over whatever
it was, 10, 15 years,
along with the drop in the
intermediation spreads.
They infer that from the drop
in the intermediation spreads
and the capital output ratio.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So the assumption
that the probability of getting
[INAUDIBLE] is decreasing.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this is a scale effect.
This came up in Alp's
lecture the other day
as well, which is if you have
a fixed cost of monitoring
or something, and then the
country gets richer and richer,
and credit is going
up and up, then
basically, the cost
of verification
is going down and down.
But here, a country's
getting richer and richer,
and you don't want this sort
of information imperfection
to go away other than
through investment
in improved technology.
So it allows that--
I guess that conceptually,
it's like bunch of little firms
all spread out.
And the bigger the loan
size, the more plants
you got to go to see-
something like that.
AUDIENCE: And is
the result partially
depending on this assumption?
Because it might be
the direction is--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
It matters quite a bit.
Now, this is kind of linear.
If it's diminishing, the
effect eventually goes away.
If it's convex, then I
don't know what happens.
But it matters.
All right.
So that's the spirit
of that paper.
Again, hopefully, it
whets your appetite and--
or at least you can get
some sense of what people
are doing in the literature.
And there's one
other that I want
to talk about before we get to
the main paper of this lecture.
And this I discovered
recently, actually--
"International Capital
Flows and Credit Markets--
A Tale of Two Frictions."
Somehow everyone's got
taken with Dickens.
The one we looked at last time
was "A Tale of Two Sectors."
I don't know whether you
thought that was clever or not.
This paper was
written after that.
So it's kind of
intriguing, and I'm not
quite sure I totally believe it.
But let me try to
walk you through it.
So the idea is we
see a lot of capital
moving around the world,
and we see boom/bust cycles.
And they're going to try
to get both of those things
in into one model.
So it's ambitious.
Global imbalances, large
and persistent capital
flows coming out
of Asia to the US--
we talked about that
last time in the--
last time in the China paper.
And there the idea is it's
hard to make good use of it
within China for the reasons
that that model and others
postulate, namely,
financial friction.
So then it should
go somewhere else.
But you could also think about
it on the other side of it.
This is the tricky part.
Namely, that that money is
going to unproductive investment
in the US.
So at least that's
ex post the judgment.
So then you have to
model sort of what's
going on with the US interest
rate that would allow
the existence of bad
projects and the coexistence
of bad projects
with good projects.
So they try to do both.
So again, there's
credit market which
intermediates the money
that comes from savers
and goes to investors.
Individuals are endowed
with some resources
and with an investment project.
And they have to decide
whether to do the project
and become an
entrepreneur, in which case
they're going to want
some credit to fund it,
or to forego their project and
become savers, in which case
they supply resources
to the credit market.
Now, this building block is the
same on almost all the papers
that we've looked at.
It's an occupation
choice model of--
that's used to address
financial issues.
To give adverse
selection a crucial role,
we assume individual
productivity
is private information and
unobservable by the lenders.
That kind of sounds like the
previous Greenwood paper.
So there is some
cross-subsidization
between high and low
productivity entrepreneurs.
A key assumption-- there's
only one interest rate.
So there's no menu of contracts.
There's no other ways to
separate good from bad.
And the thing, to
say it intuitively,
about adverse selection
is, who wants to borrow
at a given interest rate?
Well, that's really
attractive for people who
expect never to repay loans.
So the lender is going to
have to somehow break even
on those bad types that
are indistinguishable
from the good types.
And that is a force
determining the interest rate.
Now, the question is whether
that kind of perverse dynamics
would move around
with wealth and so on.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are the lenders
endowed with mechanisms
to prevent that?
Is there physical
collateral, or is there
some sort of reputation--
PROFESSOR: Not here.
Not here.
But there is a big
literature that argues--
AUDIENCE: OK.
So in this-- this
environment has
the potential for the sort of
adverse selection [INAUDIBLE]
type things.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
There is always an issue in
papers and as researchers
at what-- how much-- how
many substantive things you
want going on at the same time.
I would say this is among
the simpler adverse selection
thing.
Personally, I would always
think menus of contracts
could select--
allow selection or
sort of truth-telling.
And that's just shut down.
But Rothschild/Stiglitz
shut that down.
So maybe that's off to
a tradition of sorts.
So what are the implications
of this adverse selection?
The interest rate has
to be higher than it
would have been otherwise.
But on the other
hand, there's a lot
of borrowing and investment.
Now, be careful here, because
these low productivity
guys are happy to be borrowers.
So not all borrowing
is a good thing.
And that's kind of the seeds
of the bust getting created.
Because of adverse
selection we have
this wedge between the
equilibrium interest rate
and the marginal
return to investment.
Again, it's a common wedge.
We just did an
interest rate spread.
Here's another way to
think about that spread.
That doesn't mean
it doesn't matter.
The underlying
assumptions do matter.
But this phenomenon is pervasive
across countries in the data,
and is a big part of
almost all these models.
So adverse selection
means that the economy
can attract more
capital, and boost in
that capital flows seems
odd just to say it there.
You can see it written.
But again, the idea is that
somehow the interest rate
is higher than it would have
been in the full information
economy, and outside investors
seek the higher interest.
So that's kind of what
they mean by that.
But the true marginal return
lies below the interest rate.
So something bad is happening.
And the way it comes out in
the bath here is the capital--
there's lower aggregate
consumption because you've
used resources inefficiently.
And then they claim this
adverse selection actually
is a force for volatility.
This is kind of key.
The incentives of less
productive individuals
to become entrepreneurs
are strongest--
there's bad types borrow and
don't expect to repay much.
That force is strongest,
ironically, when the capital
stock is low and income is low.
And what's that all about?
Well, basically this
debt overhang problem
is more severe when the
capital stock is low,
because you have to borrow more
than you would if the capital
stock were high, and you
could almost self-finance.
And there's a lot of
untalented firms borrowing
when the total income and
capital stock of the economy
is low.
Or conversely, as capital
and income increases,
that cross-subsidization
is decreasing.
There's more self-financing,
and entrepreneurship
loses its appeal for less
productive individuals.
Well, I mean, it's actually
kind of interesting.
Because you can see the
dynamics of occupation choice
that we've had in
the other papers.
Who's going to be a firm
as opposed to a wage earner
depends on what happens
if you were a firm
and decided to borrow.
And then they actually
get a boom/bust cycle.
They claim to show that capital
inflows are going to fuel
this accumulation period.
And then you'll
get a contraction.
Actually, toward the end, the
tale of two obstacles or two
frictions, is they throw
pledgeability on top of it.
So the more traditional sort
of collateral constraint
reduces investment and
lowers the interest rate.
We've seen that, right?
You can't borrow as much,
so there's less pressure
on the interest rate.
So the interest
rate would be lower.
Ironically, that low
interest rate, though,
decreases the
returns to savings.
And why be a wage earner and get
a lower return on your savings
when you can be a not
so good entrepreneur
and borrow money
at low interest?
So you get this
sort of, they claim,
a kind of accelerator
or exacerbating feature,
that the adverse
selection is interacting
with the limited
collateral constraint.
And that should whet your
appetite for that paper.
Now again, I apologize in a way,
although it wasn't my intention
to go through all the
details of that paper.
And it is on the
Stellar website.
And we can study
it in more detail.
But I offered it
here just to show
you the kinds of
phenomenon that people
are trying to address
with the interplay
of financial frictions.
And then we come to the
paper I wish to focus on,
which is, again, a
tale of two frictions.
But we can't use that title.
But we're doing it
in a different way.
We allow moral hazard and
also limited commitment.
So on the one hand,
we're going to take
the traditional limited
commitment constraint
and remove it, and
insert a moral hazard
constraint explicitly.
And this time, I can
show you the equations.
But we also allow--
we don't get rid of the
capital constraint entirely.
And then you say, well,
what are the rules here
for making this stuff up?
And my answer is the data.
And in particular-- this is
the reverse order coming here--
you will see a paper
that I've written
with Alex Karaivanov, where
we have consumption, output,
investment, and
capital stock data,
and we actually estimate a
variety of financial regimes.
And it turns out that the
so-called limited commitment
regime fits the data best in
the rural data that I have
and in the Northeast, and
the moral hazard regime
fits better in the urban
areas and in the areas
in and around Bangkok.
So that's the way to think
about these two frictions.
They're, for us, going
to be microfounded.
Although here, we're just
borrowing that and putting it
in.
So--
AUDIENCE: Sir.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So
basically, are you--
you're going to sort of let
these two things interplay,
and you're going to
have them be differently
important in different places.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's where we end up.
And where we start is
we have an economy,
and I'll tell you all
about the environment.
And then I'll describe what goes
on with the limited commitment
constraint as if it
were the whole economy.
I'll do the same for moral
hazard, the whole economy.
Then I'll have like 50-50, and
use the general equilibrium.
And the punch line is going
to be the general equilibrium
with the two
frictions is not just
a simple convex combination
of the two extremes.
And the reason that
that's going on
has to do with the
general equilibrium.
So you're going to get--
roughly, you're going to get
interest rates and wages that
are somewhat between
the two extremes.
But then given
that, the question
about who is to be a firm or a
worker depends on the obstacles
that you face.
And actually, what
turns out to be
cool at the parameters we have,
which we think are reasonable
and are largely similar
to what Alex and I had,
that in the places
with moral hazard,
output is substantially higher.
There are slightly
more firms there.
They're larger.
Those firms are renting more
capital or borrowing more.
The ratio of credit to GDP,
the financing ratio, is higher.
And they employ more labor.
Without any geography
somehow, we've created these--
replicated these stylized
facts of development
when you think about rural
areas versus urban areas.
Money is flowing from
savings in rural areas
to the urbanizing cities.
Now, I'm not going to claim that
we've captured everything going
on in all these countries.
But this simple
sort of combination
of financial
frictions allows that.
In that sense, this is very
different from the other paper.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: And so do you have
something that endogenously
makes these two regimes being
relevant in those areas?
PROFESSOR: That's a good
question, and it's--
at this point, it's
hard to answer.
I mean, it looks
as if either there
is a legal restriction
on collateral,
or the set of financial
institutions that are operating
in the rural areas is
different from what's
going on in the urban areas.
And if we were going to
follow Jeremy's path,
we would ask your question.
We are asking, and we just
don't have answers yet,
as to what is the configuration
of the financial service
providers?
You'll see there is a
heavy distinction-- we've
already seen, actually, where
the commercial banks are
operating and where this
government agricultural bank is
operating.
And I think that's
probably part of the story.
But in this paper, we do
not take a stand on it.
We take as given just
this sort of difference
in the financial
information regime.
OK.
So this, we've already said.
This, we've already
talked about.
So we get to the model.
So a household that could
decide to be either a wage
earner or a firm will maximize
discounted expected utility.
Beta is the discount rate.
u is the common utility
function, the
arguments of which are
consumption of this household i,
and effort of this household i.
We'll parameterize this when
we need to compute something.
At this level,
it's quite general.
You can-- if x is equal--
this is like a binary choice.
You can be a worker or a firm.
By convention, when x
is 1, you're a firm,
and when x is zero,
you're a worker.
And that's going
to be endogenous.
If you do become a firm, you
have this productivity draw z,
and it evolves over
time according to sort
of a standard Markov process.
I was rushing toward the end
of the lecture last time,
but this was the thing
that was in the [INAUDIBLE]
paper toward the
end, and I guess
in some of the other papers.
And finally, we have wealth.
So at the beginning
of the period,
everyone has some
predetermined level of wealth,
and it's in the
bank essentially.
And so an individual
is characterized
by their initial wealth
and their current talent.
Here is the production function.
It's diminishing returns
to scale in capital
and hired labor.
And then we have these sort
of things out front here.
The notation varies from
one paper to the next.
But epsilon is here,
an idiosyncratic shock.
iid over households, and z
is that level of productivity
we already talked about
that's evolving over time.
Now, there's
actually-- the effort
of the entrepreneur is
another factor of production.
And that's basically little e.
So the way that the effort of
the entrepreneur is modeled
is through this.
The epsilon, the
idiosyncratic productivity,
depends on how hard the
entrepreneur is, quote,
"working," or
thinking, you know,
staying up at night worrying--
basically, due diligence.
This is not measured.
You do see the epsilon,
but you don't see the e.
And that's if-- well, at least
in the moral hazard model,
you don't see the e.
But I should qualify
that we're going
through the standard
environment,
and there's going to
be a full information
environment with limited
commitment in which everything
is seen and full
insurance is possible,
versus the moral hazard
environment which
is going to be the source
of limited insurance,
and it's going to interact--
both frictions interact
with productivity.
So there are banks or
financial intermediaries,
and you should think of them
as basically risk syndicates.
Because not only do they sort
of lend out of the wealth
that households have been
depositing with them,
they can also smooth over
idiosyncratic shocks.
So there's a state
contingent payment
that the banks can make--
it could be negative--
say, to the households
as a function
of their realized
and observed epsilon.
Now, in some
respects, it's still--
we're not solving a
massive programming problem
and then capturing
the interest rates
and wages off some
first order conditions.
Instead, we're going to
imagine that these risk
syndicates, these banks, and
the firms and the households
all take as given economy-wide
interest rates and wages.
And like many of
the other papers,
we're going to have to determine
those by supply and demand
mechanically.
So that's a
computational burden,
but it is one that other
papers have faced as well.
Now, what to do about talent--
is it insurable or not?
Well, we kind of decided
to try to be realistic
and to not let it be insured.
We could go the other way.
In some sense, we know
exactly how to do it.
And there's some duals
which would be satisfied
if we had allowed it.
But we thought it was just
on the side of realism
to say don't worry
about your job market.
We're going to cover that.
NYT is going to
fully insure you.
Well, of course, we could put
moral hazard on the z thing.
But anyway, we
didn't get into that.
So you're going assign the
occupation, induce effort--
where did I say--
I guess I didn't say it.
It'll come up in a
second, hopefully.
Yeah.
It was right here.
We actually also
allow there to be
some insurance and moral hazard
issues on the worker side.
Now, for simplicity, we give
them this same p of e function.
We could have allowed
it to be different.
What is this?
Well, the idea is you can
sort of put a lot of effort
into working, and
the firm is going
to observe your total
sort of productivity.
But the firm doesn't
see your effort.
It's like piece
rate in some sense.
So we just got tired
of being asymmetric,
as so many papers are about--
you know, there's an insurance
problem for intermediaries
and wage earners don't
suffer from things like that.
So here's the timeline.
The household comes in with--
a certain household i comes
in with a certain amount
of wealth and talent.
There's going to be an
assignment, if you will,
of who's a worker or a firm.
Then if a firm--
well, if a worker or firm ever
gets determined, if a firm--
the capitalization and
labor hiring of the firm
gets determined, then
the epsilon hits.
Effort comes first.
Epsilon comes after that and
gets in the way, so to speak,
especially if effort
is not observed.
So this is like idiosyncratic
risk subject to moral hazard
potentially.
Then consumption and the
level of your savings
that you're carrying
over putting
into the bank for
tomorrow, those things
are functions potentially
of those epsilons.
So the point is, you do
bear the consequences
in the moral hazard
model of shirking.
If you shirked and
your productivity
were low as a
consequence of that,
you're going to have
to take a hit in terms
of lower consumption and lower
savings from tomorrow on.
So here's the optimization
problem really of the bank,
but it's more like an
equilibrium outcome.
The banks are
basically competitive.
There's free entry.
And for any sort of cohort
fully observed, by the way,
az sort of people out there--
there's a lot of them in
every little cubbyhole--
the banks compete to
offer them contracts.
In effect, they
would bid down things
until utility is maximized.
So it's as if they're maximizing
the utility of this cohort
by choice of all these
things I just went through.
And this is the
resource constraint
that the risk syndicate faces.
Partly it's familiar
and partly not.
Namely, you've got
uses and sources.
The uses of money or resources
is in consumption and how much
you save for next time.
And the sources
comes from if you're
a firm in this syndicate,
your net profits,
after subtracting off the
cost of labor and capital
and depreciating the capital,
and from the other guys
who are wage earners.
And as is standard
in many models,
you begin the period with
basically the savings
that you had as a bank.
But now they've sort
of accrued interest.
So you have principal
and interest
at the beginning of the period.
Now, it looks like a standard
sort of incomplete markets
model, where you have the
choices between saving
and, quote, "borrowing/lending."
The difference here and-- well,
and some profit maximization
embedded.
But the difference really
is the summing over epsilon.
So this is the total sort
of assigned consumption
and savings throughout
the whole syndicate,
the average per capita number.
And this is the
per capita sources.
The intermediaries in trying
to break even on every epsilon
type in the population--
that's the risk-sharing
part of it,
that some people could
have higher output
than other people.
but subject to
incentives or insurance.
The intermediary will smooth
that by assigning, say,
higher consumption than output
for the low epsilon guys,
and conversely for
the high epsilon guys.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the financial
intermediary, they
can control the distribution
between consumption and asset?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's all observed.
AUDIENCE: So household
can't bypass that
by saving themselves.
PROFESSOR: They don't.
Yeah.
We assume not.
But you could
assume that they get
their sort of
assignment of assets,
and then they act on their own.
But they would
put it in the bank
because they accrue interest.
So there's really no loss in
letting it sit in the bank.
Now, we can have banks
competing with one another.
That's a bit more subtle.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
other way around though, right?
PROFESSOR: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: You
can't like really--
OK.
Like, the household
can choose to save,
but household can
choose to consume too?
I don't know.
I feel that here, bank has
more control over household,
and they can say exactly
how much you can--
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
probably a better way
to think about it anyway.
Because as you'll see,
these information frictions
and collateral
restrictions create
pressures that make savings more
or less than what households
might want to do if they were
just following their Euler
equation.
So in the end, I agree with you.
What's going to be
actually interesting
is that it's going--
and you'll see this--
it's going to go
a different way.
In the collateral
constraint model,
you would like to
borrow more, actually,
in order to have more
assets in the future.
That's not allowed to happen.
So they're going to be
borrowing-constrained
in terms of looking at their
intertemporal consumption path.
The guy subject to this sort
of incentive moral hazard
constraint, they're
actually going to end up
being savings-constrained.
They would like to save more.
So it's already a hint that
the dynamics of the household
decision problems
are very different,
not just of the firm,
but the households.
So what do we mean by
the incentive constraint?
Well, when effort
is unobserved, you
want to induce the
assigned effort.
So these are the good boys.
They were recommended to do
e, and they actually do it.
So this is the distribution
of output, epsilon,
that results from it.
And they go into tomorrow
with the assigned levels
of savings and draw talent.
But effort is not seen.
So they actually
contemplate some
out of equilibrium
behavior, like doing
e hat, which is other than e.
Now, what are the
consequences of that?
Well, first of all, there's
a direct consequence
in the utility function,
because shirking
might be good in terms
of higher utility.
But also, there is
a direct consequence
in terms of the
distribution of output.
So this is sort of the
moral hazard induced
productivity consequence.
And if you do some typical
monotonicity or something,
then higher effort is
associated with likely
getting higher epsilons.
So that's a standard-looking
incentive constraint.
The-- yes.
AUDIENCE: So probably
we could introduce
some costs associated
with changing jobs
between [INAUDIBLE].
Does it change the
analysis at all?
PROFESSOR: Well,
you get to choose.
But yeah.
There's no extra cost.
It would increase the
dimensionality of the state
space rather enormously,
because then you'd not only
have to worry about the
current distribution of wealth
and talent, you'd have to worry
about what these guys were
doing last period.
And it's actually hard enough
to get any kind of solutions,
analytic or numeric.
So I think that's the constraint
here is keeping the state.
I mean, there is-- you'll
see that there's already
a huge distribution
of wealth, and we're
going to have to keep track of
how that histogram is evolving
the population jointly with
the talent distribution.
So hopefully, good
enough for starters.
Oh.
I'm going to skip this slide.
I'll tell you what was on it,
and then we'll come back to it
when we get to the microdata.
Basically, instead
of solving directly
for consumption as a function of
epsilon and all of that stuff,
we trick it into a linear
programming problem.
And we do that by keeping
track of histograms of things,
basically, the joint
distribution of consumption,
epsilon, recommended effort and
so on, respecting the timing.
So in words, hopefully,
you would think
that's kind of equivalent.
Anyway.
Now, what's the gain?
The gain is it literally
is a linear program.
So that little module can be
solved as a linear programming
problem, and that's
how we're computing
the solutions to that part.
But this isn't the right
context to go into the notation.
We'll do it in a very simple
convex cost or a fixed cost
problem first, and then
build up to it later.
So I'm missing something.
Oh, yeah.
This thing.
So this is the other constraint,
that the capitalization
of the firm is just some
proportion of your wealth.
Lambda could be greater than
1, but it's not infinity.
So this is the
constraint that we had
on so many of the other papers.
And you can tell
stories and model
this about running away
with a capital and so on.
But this is the essence of it.
We could do both.
We're going to imagine
that it's one or the other.
I mean, both simultaneously
for a given firm.
But we're going to put people
in one sector or the other.
So then we're going to solve for
the factors occupation choice,
labor, hiring, capitalization.
And you want to think
about labor supply--
it's just only slightly tricky.
X means entrepreneur.
1 minus x means wage earner.
What's the total labor supply
coming from wage earners?
Well, epsilon is
units of labor supply.
It's induced by the effort.
There's a histogram.
So we basically add up
overall the epsilons
at the fractions with which
they exist in the population.
And this is total labor supply.
And so then the rest
is pretty less daunting
in terms of notation.
We have-- we're going to equate
labor supply to labor demand.
This is the l being
employed within the firms.
The firms vary in
terms of their a and z.
And everyone's facing
these economy-wide wage
and interest rates.
But this does depend
on the az argument,
so we have to add up over--
or integrate up over-- all the
az people in the population.
So again, in
practice, we're going
to have a large finite
number of wealths,
a finite number of
talents, and this is going
to be some kind of summation.
This is also the capital
clearing constraint.
All that wealth sitting
there-- forget the d.
Don't know why that's there.
You have all that wealth
sitting in the bank,
and it's going to be lent out
at interest to the firms that
are renting the capital.
So we grab some parameters
and some functional forms.
These are pretty traditional.
I guess we didn't want to
do anything unconventional,
because we want to show what
difference the obstacles make
rather than force you
into a utility function
you don't believe.
Also, we can grab from the
literature values for these
that people believe.
I don't mean to belittling
calibration all the time.
Beta is realistic here.
It's about basically 5%, or
95% of the future is valued.
Sigma's the degree
of risk aversion.
It's 1.5.
People have values well
within that range--
just utility is a bit tricky
to parameterize of effort,
but the power function
is the Frisch elasticity.
People have estimated that.
This is a simple transition
which we made up.
But in other papers, people talk
about entry and exit of firms,
and we could imagine doing that.
And they are also
similar to the parameters
that Alex and I estimate would
likely [INAUDIBLE] functions.
So here is the--
with the Euler equation,
it's at the household side.
Borrowing-constrained households
have a Lagrange multiplier
on that limited
commitment constraint.
It turns out to be tomorrow,
but in expectation, it
leads to this same phenomenon
that the marginal utility
of consumption is high today and
lower in expectation tomorrow.
So these guys are
borrowing-constrained.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Question, sir--
going back to [INAUDIBLE]..
So when you
described it earlier,
so something that entrepreneur
can do to [INAUDIBLE]
to make productivity high.
If it was mainly
labor monitoring,
I guess it would maybe sort of
really only scale with labor.
Would that-- how much
would that change
what goes on in the model.
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's a
bit like in the spirit
of Jeremy's model, and
we're not doing that.
But yes, you could put--
it's very much like
what Jeremy is doing.
You could put the technology
for monitoring effort
to create a signal
at least of effort,
and that would mitigate--
that would move us
more toward the full
insurance solution.
And this is the weird one.
And I'm not sure if you've
seen this yet or not
in public finance.
But-- so I'm just going
to basically assert
that the first order
condition, when
you're subject to moral
hazard, looks like this.
And for obvious reasons,
this is sometimes
called the inverse
Euler equation,
because this is 1 over u prime.
The point here is
Jensen's inequality.
You know, if you replace--
if you pull the expectation
operator outside of it,
you'd have 1 over u
prime, but the inverse
would take it back to u prime.
But when you move that
expectation operator outside,
you're taking an average
over the interior object.
I'm sorry.
This is an average over the
interior object as opposed
to an integration
from the outside.
So it is basically a classical
example of Jensen's inequality,
and it makes the
right-hand side higher.
That's mechanical,
but hopefully--
we've already talked about this.
You can see that in
the limited commitment,
people cannot borrow
as much as they want.
That's going to make the
demand for funds less,
and the interest
rate is going to be
less when all the economy
is subject from that limited
commitment
constraint, as opposed
to the moral hazard economy
where households and firms are
savings-constrained.
So they would like to save more.
Savings is less.
It's scarce.
You have a higher interest rate.
So these interest rate
numbers kind of make sense.
Don't be too spooked by
the negative interest rate.
You know, we have a depreciation
rate in this economy.
So it's still sort of on net--
it's positive.
And then you can see, comparing
these two different countries,
GDP, TFP--
the TFP dynamics
are very different,
although the numbers,
though different,
are not radically different.
TFP is dragged down in the
limited commitment economy,
because high productivity firms
cannot borrow as much as they
want.
They can't exploit their z.
Whereas, in the
moral hazard economy,
you have to induce effort,
and that's kind of a drag.
I mean, if you were draconian
and you had no insurance,
then yes, people would
be working very hard.
But that's actually not optimal.
The right thing to do is to have
this blend between insurance
and productivity.
So partially, it's-- this
language people use about moral
hazard in the banking
system and in the press
and the policymakers,
pick that up like,
let's get rid of moral hazard.
That's not the right
way to think about it.
Moral hazard is an
information problem.
You want incentives
to do as best you can,
given the moral hazard problem.
But it's like-- eliminate
moral hazard is like, let's
just shut down
all the insurance,
then you don't have a problem.
But yeah, well, you
got other problems.
Wages are a bit different.
They're higher in
the moral-- these
are economy-wide wages and
interest rates, of course.
But you can also see
a bigger difference
in the financing ratio.
Actually, labor here tends
to compensate for the more
restricted capital, and
the drag makes labor lower
in the moral hazard economy.
External finance is more limited
in the limited commitment
economy.
Why?
Because you can't borrow.
You run into that
lambda constraint.
There's nothing like that
in the moral hazard economy.
So the external finance
to GDP ratio is higher.
AUDIENCE: So why is the
interest rate negative?
PROFESSOR: That's,
again, because there's
an interest rate going on here.
I mean capital gets
utilized, and it gets--
it's depreciating.
And you've got to basically
pay for that somehow.
So it lowers the net yield.
And here's
interesting-- you know,
I didn't get to say much at
all about Joaquin Blaum's paper
on inequality.
But I get to be reminded
to say something now,
because here the wealth
inequality curve's generated
by the different constraints.
And you can see there's
actually more inequality
in the limited
commitment economy
than there is in the
moral hazard economy.
But again, that has to do with
this dispersion of the capital.
Capital tends to be more--
not identical, but
more compressed
in the moral hazard economy.
And capital is very limited.
You can't take advantage of your
productivity in the other one.
So the wealth dispersion
is playing a bigger role,
and feeding back in turn to--
it's like you can't
get the convergences.
And then we take 50-50.
Same economy-- now we have the
urban/rural of the same size,
and--
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So in the slides
with the parameters,
you don't talk about lambda.
How much do you
think that to be?
The-- so the-- how
much is the constraint?
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure
I remember the number.
AUDIENCE: But-- I mean, do you
remember how you configured it?
PROFESSOR: It should have been
on that list of parameters?
It wasn't on that page?
No.
I don't remember.
We probably-- it was
probably something like 1.3,
because that's--
but that's right off
the top of my head.
AUDIENCE: How do you--
[INAUDIBLE] in the same way?
Because that's
how-- like, that's
something you estimated
somewhere else?
PROFESSOR: Hopefully,
we just drew it
from this literature,
the [INAUDIBLE] paper
that you've seen before.
I don't think we
matched it with data.
That's actually hard to
pin down in the data.
AUDIENCE: Would
it be particularly
sensitive to the
choice of lambda?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Remember the [INAUDIBLE]
thing, where lambda goes from--
I think it was 1.3 to infinity.
And at infinity, there's
no constraint at all.
You're back to the full
insurance, full productivity
solution.
AUDIENCE: So some
of the things about
like the wealth
inequality and [INAUDIBLE]
expect those [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
Now what-- so what
you're not seeing here,
although we have
recently done this,
is run a whole suite of
computations for all kinds
of-- we put sort of error
bands or confidence intervals
on these just to make sure that
none of the things that we want
to emphasize are--
either they're
always true, or we're
going to say they're
not always true,
and they depend on
these parameters.
But you're absolutely
right, that just showing
some simulations looks a
bit arbitrary, especially
for things like lambda,
which I'm not even
remembering in the moment, so--
But different things would
matter for the moral hazard
economy too.
You know, the curvature of
the labor supply utility
that generates labor supply--
that's going to be
that Frisch elasticity.
We'll see that again when we
get to the sort of microdata.
And the chi that sits in
front of labor disutility--
that's a huge number,
important number.
So what are these slides?
Well, this is a
bit like generating
many, many, many simulations.
We have many economies,
and we vary this fraction
from zero to one.
I just showed you
the 50-50 economy.
But this allows everyone to be
in limited commitment, everyone
to be in moral hazard,
or anywhere in between.
And so you can see how
GDP, TFP, and so on,
how these things move
around with the fraction
of the population that are
subject to moral hazard.
And partly, this mirrors what
I said before in labor supply.
But on other things, you can
see things aren't monotone.
So those are surprises.
It actually goes up, and
then it comes down again.
GDP climbs pretty fast,
and then it kind of
wobbles around a bit.
We've tried to get rid of
as many wobbles as possible
for worries that they're
just computational.
But some of them-- some
of the wobbles remain.
So I've kind of learned to
not pay too much attention.
But this is not numerical error.
This is systematic, this drop.
And you can see what the
wages and the interest rates
are doing, and the fraction
of firms for that matter.
Now, here is back to 1/2, 1/2.
But within that economy, we have
the limited commitment sector
and the moral hazard sector.
Obviously, there is
economy-wide wages
and interest rates are the same.
It's one economy clearing.
But other things vary
across these two columns.
Probably the most
exciting part is
this, which is let's look
at labor, for example.
Labor employed in
the sector 0.38;
labor supplied by
the sector 0.53.
So they're exporters
of labor, if you allow
me to use that terminology.
Or people are
costlessly migrating
from the limited commitment
sector to the moral hazard.
And indeed, you'll pick up
the other side of this thing,
basically, labor supplied,
0.46; labor demanded, 0.61.
Now, you say, why isn't
it all zero and one.
No, no, no, no, no.
Remember the z's.
Remember the productivity.
Every sector has some
really inefficient people
who shouldn't be running firms.
They're going to supply
labor no matter what,
or at least at these
equilibrium wages.
And the same thing is true
with the flow of funds
if we had the geographic
decomposition--
and we got Mexico to
do this, by the way.
It's really cool--
through their CNBV,
their financial regulator.
And the question
there, is money flowing
to Mexico City from
the outlying areas
as they improve intermediation?
And what consequences does that
have for the outlying areas?
Well, here, money's flowing from
the limited commitments sector
to the moral hazard sector.
So this is where the
action is, so to speak.
We don't get a lot of
difference in terms
of the numbers of firms,
but you're clearly
seeing differences in
terms of employment size.
And remember the China paper
was like this, where labor--
the allocation of labor
was playing a huge role.
So-- sorry.
We had more results
over the weekend.
We've been trying to get these.
This, we've had for
a long time, but I'll
show you something else
that's quite exciting.
First of all, speed
of transitions--
you remember that where a paper
was all about the puzzle, which
is, why don't miracle
Asian economies grow
even faster if you believe
they were in a solo world?
But of course, there is--
and then they assume
this financial friction,
which slowed things down.
The friction you assume is
going to make a big difference
to the speed of transitions.
Actually, here, even
in the steady state,
you can ask how fast do
people go from an az state
to an a prime z prime state?
This is some big Markov matrix.
It's sort of steady
state, but it's
transition from
the household level
from one state to another.
So you may remember, you
can multiply those matrices
over and over times each
other, or you can basically
do an eigenvalue,
eigenvector decomposition.
And the closer this eigenvalue
is to 1, the slower things are.
Things are moving.
The next multiplication
of the matrix
is kind of very similar--
that times the
control [INAUDIBLE]
very similar to what is
in the previous period.
It's 0.93.
That's a very-- sorry.
0.93 for one; 0.98
for the other.
So there's roughly three
more times difference
in the speed of sort of within
steady state transitions going
on.
Now, there's a technical
reason for this, basically.
On the limited
commitment thing we
have this forward-looking
savings behavior.
So people are going
to save their way out
of these constraints.
And they can do
it pretty quickly.
In fact, you're going
to see some homework
and so on motivated by thinking
through [INAUDIBLE] papers
and job market papers
and so on, that kind of
get at this thing, which is--
the twist is, why doesn't money
flow from the US to India?
The answer is, why doesn't India
save its way out of constraints
more quickly than they seem to?
So there's discussion in
the literature about that.
But here we do have constraints.
It's just that
they're different.
And essentially
what's going on here
is you don't want to--
you don't want that wealth
to move very fast.
You're going to balance
off the incentives
of today's consumption
versus tomorrow's wealth.
Wealth moves a little bit,
depending on whether epsilon
is high or low.
But you don't want it
to move a whole lot.
Because if it did, that's
the bulk of your utility.
That's kind of very--
that is actually
algebraically in the dual,
equivalent with discounted
expected utility.
And so if you move
that quickly, there's
a big welfare loss
because of the concavity.
So you don't want
it to move fast.
So that's-- OK.
And then if you look
at growth rates,
the distribution of growth
rates looks like it's all zero.
Actually, what the point
is, the growth rates
are all very similar
to each other,
because there isn't this big
dispersion in the moral hazard
economy because they
don't move that fast.
But a limited
commitment-- there's
a huge dispersion
and growth rate.
And you can imagine going to
data with this kind of stuff.
We didn't look at
this in the data.
But if you have Panel,
you can actually
look not only at static
firm size distributions
but the growth rates, and
get some evidence one way
or the other for one friction.
Then finally, the weekend--
we've had a devil of
a time doing this.
We start with the
whole economy subject
to a limited
commitment constraint.
And then we move it after 10
periods to a moral hazard.
Now, this is meant to mimic
some kind of financial reform.
If you want to be
generous with me,
think of there being
two constraints,
and then we managed
to get rid of one.
Well, that's not quite
what we're doing.
We kind of substitute limited
commitment for moral hazard.
Basically, they get rid of
a constraining legal system,
but it turns out that created
an information problem.
Anyway, what's
really important is
that you can actually look
at the transition dynamics.
Well, let me just
show you the pictures.
So here, you're
in a steady state,
and then you do a
financial reform.
But it's not like--
Kaboski, they did-- they left
the financial structure intact,
and they did real reforms.
We're leaving everything in
the environment and everything
intact and doing a
financial reform, hopefully
in the spirit of what
Levine might have wanted.
And then we see the implications
of that for deeper levels
of capitalization.
And look at the wage rate.
It's no wonder we had
trouble finding it--
pops up like that
instantaneously.
Now, let me just say, these
things are not easy to compute.
Because-- and [INAUDIBLE]
going to say something
about that on Friday.
Essentially, when you're
out of the steady state,
you have to figure out
where you're going to go
and how long it's going
to take to get there.
And then you've got
to sort of guess
about the paths of the
interest rates and the wages.
And of course, any arbitrary
guess about how long it takes
and how they're going to
move is quite arbitrary.
So then you need
a systematic way
to adjust period by period
to get in new guesses
and then to try to iterate.
[INAUDIBLE] managed to do it.
We have their code.
I've shared it
with many students
working on related problems.
It turned out that
their code, which
is getting better and better
because they're playing around
with it too, works for this
limited commitment better--
much, much better than
it ever worked for us
with moral hazard.
We were quite
despondent about being
able to compute the transitions.
But evidently, now we're
in business on that.
So the summary, back
to the big picture,
is these obstacles matter.
Ideally, I think,
if you can manage,
use the microdata to try
to take a stand on what
the frictions are.
And through the dynamics
of Euler equations and debt
overhang and so on, you'll
generate these dynamic paths.
And they're going to
be general equilibrium
consequences of the reforms.
So it's like doing an
experiment on these economies
to see what would happen.
And this allows us to begin to
answer those questions I went
over in the introductory lecture
about finance causes growth,
but then what?
What do we do?
And how do we engineer it?
And what would we
expect to happen?
And are there winners
and losers, and so on?